[Applause]
throughout the day supporters and
opponents of abortion faced off in front
of Colombia's highest court pro-choice
activists hope magistrates would give
women the right to terminate pregnancies
of up to 16 weeks in the end the court
chose to leave abortion laws as they are
but at the same time we are happy that
the lawsuit that attend to take away our
rights was not successful there are
three grounds for abortion in Colombia
opponents say they already go too far
article 11 of the Constitution says life
should never be dishonoured but there
are deranged people who support these
shameful reasons no more no more
the latest debate rose from a case
seeking a return to a total ban after
the court allowed abortion in three
instances in 2016 if the mother's life
is at risk if the fetus is malformed or
in case of rape but even in these cases
many obstacles remain for women to
access the procedure especially if
they're poor or live in rural areas
despite the restrictions health
authorities say that at least 400,000
women terminates their pregnancies every
year here in Colombia most of them do so
illegally and in many cases suffer
serious health consequences human rights
professor Luce Angela Gomez is one of
them she sought an abortion when she was
17 at any legal clinic getting a
dangerous infection as a result or
shion's happen and will keep happening
illegally even in three legal cases
women face undue delays and obstacles
and often resort to unsafe options
facing more problems and even death the
latest case has intensified an already
fierce debate in the country over the
legal and moral implication of abortion
which both sighs promise to keep
fighting for
Alessandra MPT al-jazeera Bogota